hi remember me I'm Loki the Angel of  Death from Dogma I had a couple of roles  and Kevin's I played like an M TV  executive and another one it was like a  couple lines I just tried it when in the  90s when Ben and was doing all these  movies with Kevin like I just try to get  in them any way I could  and then after Kevin executive produced  Good Will Hunting I remember on the set  of Good Will Hunting and Kevin offered  me Loki so it was the first time he  offered me a real a real job big job  they are reminiscent of the time and you  know and and and maybe MIT you know I  think it's partly nostalgia and partly  and partly they just they just struck a  real chord that's there that they can  still kind of strike today you know  they're funny they're you know you buy  into their relationship and and and kind  of their two guys you want to go on an  adventure with I mean that's that's  that's my take on it  [Music]